vamos a resolver la integral indefinida
de la raíz de 7 x + 9 todo esto está
dentro de la raíz diferencial de x y
bueno la pregunta es podremos resolver
esto por el método de integración que
estamos viendo es decir por la
sustitución y sí sí quién me voy a tomar
como la función así que vamos a suponer
que la función u es lo que está dentro
de la raíz si fuera lo que está dentro
de la raíz entonces quién sería su
derivada entonces sería igual a 7 x + 9
y quién va a ser la derivada de la
derivada de eeuu con respecto a x es
igual a la derivada de 7x es 7 y la
derivada una constante se va no es
necesario ponerla por lo tanto aquí el
problema es que no tenemos aquí el 7 por
ningún lado por lo tanto qué es lo que
podemos hacer y bueno uno se pondrá muy
triste porque no saben este tipo de
ejercicios sin embargo si hay forma de
resolver este tipo de integrales y la
forma es que nosotros podemos
multiplicar por un escalar o por una
constante la cual salga y entra de esta
integral y es que nosotros tenemos una
propiedad de la integral que dice algo
así
la integral es de una constante a por la
función f x diferencial de x diferencial
de x es igual a la constante a que
multiplica a la integral
efe de x diferencial de x es decir las
constantes salen afuera de la integral y
es justo esta propiedad la que voy a
utilizar para poder resolver esta
integral que tenemos en el problema
original y que es lo que voy a hacer
bueno aquí me falta un 7 que les parece
si yo multiplico por un 7 como el 7 es
una constante puedo multiplicar por el 7
porque puede salir o entrar de la
integral y dejarme para no confundirlos
ponerlo todo de este lado que me va a
quedar bueno pues esto va a ser igual a
la integral y no puedo multiplicar
solamente por un 7 también tengo que
dividir entre un 7 por lo tanto me va a
quedar un séptimo por 7 por la raíz de 7
x más 9 diferencial de x y se dan cuenta
7 por un séptimo es lo mismo que 1 por
lo tanto no estoy haciendo nada es un 1
fantasma y esto va a ser igual a un
séptimo por la integral de 7 que
multiplica a la raíz de 7 x + 9
diferencial de x
dice fue sacar esta constante que no la
necesito dentro de la integral porque la
diferencial de v con respecto a x
solamente es 7 por lo tanto ahora sí que
es lo que voy a hacer bueno la derivada
de eeuu es igual a 7 veces la
diferencial de x aquí lo único que hizo
fue pasar multiplicando la diferencia
del de x y que creen aquí está este y
este es la diferencia al de eeuu y ya la
tengo por fin y también por otra parte
lo que está dentro de la raíz es por lo
tanto ya puedo resolver esta integral
que me va a quedar bueno esto lo voy a
escribir ahora sí en términos de v es
igual a un séptimo que multiplica a la
integral de y bueno primero tengo 7 x de
x esto es la diferencial de v entonces
voy a poner aquí la raíz de lo que
estaba dentro era un que multiplica a 7
de x que es la diferencial de eeuu y
bueno esta integral de as muy sencilla
ya hicimos el cambio de variable porque
la raíz de v es lo mismo que elevado a
la un medio y entonces podemos resolver
esta integral como integral de una
variable elevar a una potencia me va a
quedar un séptimo que multiplica al ente
elevado a la un medio diferencial de
recuerden que la raíz y elevarle un
medio es lo mismo voy a poner mejor
aúlla de un color blanco para que no nos
vayamos confundiendo porque además todo
es de color amarillo es muy monótono
entonces ahora si ya tengo esta integral
y esta integral yo la puedo resolver por
la integral de una variable elevada una
potencia es decir lo que hay que hacer
es sumarle 1 la potencia y dividirlo
entre ese mismo número entonces nos
queda un séptimo no lo olvidemos que
multiplica a elevada a la un medio más
uno pero un medio más uno es lo mismo
que un medio más un medio más un medio
que son tres medios por lo tanto no
queda elevada a la tres medios lo voy a
poner con color blanco o elevado a la
tres medios entre tres medios pero si
tomamos el recíproco de tres medios es
lo mismo que dos tercios o elevada a
tres medios entre tres medios es lo
mismo que dos tercios que multiplica a
elevar a tres medios y bueno ya
resolvimos por fin ese integral
utilizando la integral de una variable
elevada una potencia a esto todavía
falta sumarle una constante de
integración y bueno ahora sí ya tengo la
integral por fin y lo que
voy a hacer ahora es multiplicar este un
séptimo por el dos tercios un séptimo
por dos tercios es lo mismo que 2 entre
21 y elevado a la tres medios más un
séptimo por una constante por el final
un séptimo por una constante es lo mismo
que una constante bueno siquiera aquí le
podemos poner constante 1 y constante 2
pero al final son constantes arbitrarias
por lo tanto pues es lo mismo que una
constante no es necesario poner
constante 1 constante 2 o las que sean
necesarias y ya casi acabamos porque
hicimos un cambio de variable ahora hay
que hacer el cambio de variable hacia
atrás eso quiere decir que hay que
sustituir en términos de la variable
original y la variable original era x
por lo tanto me queda 2 sobre 21 que
multiplica a 1 pero es lo mismo que 7 x
más 9 por lo tanto es 2 sobre 21 que
multiplica 7 x + 9 elevado a la 3 medios
más la constante de integración
y ya con esto hemos terminado no sin
antes hacerles mención de lo importante
que fue multiplicar por este 1 fantasma
es decir por 7 por un séptimo para
ajustar la integral